In a July, 2014 survey,
Google asked app developers
around the world to
share their experiences
about the mobile app
development process.
Nearly a third told us that
the most challenging area was
growing their
audience, and a quarter
said monetization
proved to be difficult.
Developers felt that these two
areas had the fewest resources
and support.
This course will hopefully
help developers solve for this.
Ads are an effective and easy
way to monetize your app.
In fact, ads are
the most common way
to make money from apps today.
Let's dive in and
review the ecosystem,
taking a look at the players
in the market and the metrics
you'll use to
measure your success.
The three players in
the advertising game
are users, advertisers,
and publishers.
Users are basically
you and me, the people
who use apps every day.
Advertisers want to reach
users, promoting their product
or brand.
Publishers offer
advertisers their inventory,
space for ads within
their apps, allowing
them to connect with
the right users.
Ideally, an advertising
network strives
to balance the needs of
each of these three players
for a win-win-win.
Now, let's explore each
player's role a bit
further, starting with the user.
As we say in Google, focus on
users and the rest will follow.
Users are a key component
of the mobile app ecosystem.
They're the ones
engaging with apps
and are really the center
of this whole app universe.
As a mobile app
developer, you constantly
want to grow, connecting
with more users who
are likely to enjoy your app.
Advertising is a great way
for you to do just that.
You have many channels available
to reach your ideal audience
and acquire new
users with Google,
including Search, Display,
YouTube and Google Play.
Before diving into
placing ads, you
want to identify your goals.
Do you want to focus on
increasing downloads?
Well, then get more
people around the world
to download your app
using app installs.
Do you want to focus on
re-engaging or existing users?
Look at deeplinking to specific
screens within your mobile app.
Do you want to get noticed
by a mobile audience?
You can show ads
for your website
exclusively in mobile apps.
No matter what your
goals with advertising,
it's important to reach a large
audience on a global scale,
showing ads that are
relevant to the user.
They'll be happy, and your
revenue will show for it.
Let's look at the
advertiser's perspective.
Advertisers want to place
their ads in high quality
applications and reach
the right audience.
The increasing
amount of time users
spend in apps provides
a valuable opportunity
for advertisers.
A window of engaged time
to reach out and promote
their offerings.
But to be successful,
advertisers
must put the needs of
the mobile user first.
At Google, we believe
at the best ad unit
is the one that gets
the interest of the user
while providing a
positive experience.
We invest a lot of resources to
offer a smart ads platform that
can target users at the right
place at the right moment
with the right message.
This gives advertisers
the best opportunity
to present their
message in a way that is
going to resonate with users.
So just how does an advertiser
gauge success on mobile?
Here are some metrics that
are typically important.
Cost per install, or CPI.
This is a fixed bid or rate
paid when an app is installed.
In other words, what it
costs to acquire a new user.
Value of impressions.
Impressions are the units
used to display an ad.
These vary in value depending
on the ad format and network.
For example, a text ad will
have less impact or value
than an interactive banner
ad or homepage takeover.
Click through rate, or CTR.
This is the ratio
of clicks on an ad
to its number of impressions.
The idea behind CTR is that
the more relevant an ad is,
the more clicks it will get.
So successful ads generally
have a higher CTR.
To calculate CTR, take
the number of clicks
that an ad receives divided
by the number of times
the ad is shown.
For example, if you had 5
clicks and 1,000 impressions,
then your CTR would be 0.5%.
Cost per click, or CPC.
This is the amount paid for
a single click on an ad.
Most advertisers use this
as their pricing model
since they are only charged
when a user clicks on their ad,
rather than paying
simply to show their ad.
Cost per 1,000 impressions.
Referred to as CPM.
This is the cost incurred for
showing an ad 1,000 times.
CPM is typically used
for building awareness,
which is achieved by
simply showing the ad.
Keeping in mind the user and
the advertiser perspectives,
let's move on to
the publisher side.
First things first, what
exactly is a publisher?
A publisher is
simply a developer
who has a mobile app that
they want to monetizing.
In this instance, this is you.
As a publisher, you'll
monetize by selling ad space
within your app to advertisers.
Advertisers pay for
this valuable space
so they can show ads
to users while they're
engaging with your app.
To maximize earnings,
it's important for you,
as a publisher, to
continually grow your audience
and keep users
engaged with your app.
This makes your ad space
more valuable to advertisers.
Here are some additional terms
that you should be aware of.
Ad request.
An ad request is counted
whenever your site requests
an ad to be displayed.
Fill rate.
This is the number of
impressions divided
by the number of ad requests.
The goal is to have a
high fill rate, meaning
that your app is
showing a lot of ads,
providing you with more revenue.
eCPM.
eCPM refers to the
estimated income
you'll see by showing 1,000
impressions in your app.
This estimation is based on
the historical performance
and is proven with RPM, the
actual amount of revenue
earned per 1,000 impressions.
Average ad revenue per user.
This is the revenue
earned from ads
divided by the total number of
users who were served the ads.
In other words, it's
the average value
of each user to
your bottom line.
While there are many mobile
ad networks out there today,
you should look carefully
at their fill rates,
eCPMs, latency, like how
quickly the ad loads,
and the quality of
the ads they show.
With ads being the most common
form of app monetization,
it makes sense that
the space is thriving
from all points of view--
the users, the advertisers,
and you, the publisher.
Ad serving networks
provide a variety of tools
to keep the app ecosystem
booming, giving users
positive, relevant
experiences, advertisers
the means to promote their
offerings, and developers a way
to earn money on their app.
Thanks for watching.
Be sure to check out other
videos from the series,
and go to google.com/admob
for more information.